[Música]
la isla de Cuba se quedó a oscuras tras
el paso del huracán la red eléctrica
colapsó además de la destrucción dejada
en la parte occidental del país por Los
Fuertes vientos y posteriores
inundaciones las autoridades trabajan
para restablecer el servicio
comenzó de manera oficial la Selección
del Jurado que llevará el caso del líder
de la Organización de extrema derecha o
skippers y cuatro de sus integrantes
todos acusados de haber participado en
el ataque al Capitolio de Estados Unidos
el 6 de enero del 2021
a pocos días de las presidenciales de
Brasil Luis Ignacio anula da Silva
aventaja por 15 puntos al presidente
Jair bolsonaro el líder del partido de
los trabajadores se está alineando con
grupos evangélicos que podrían aumentar
sus apoyos Pese a que en la elección
pasada fueron electores de base de bolso
Estas son las noticias de América en
France 24 y comenzamos la red eléctrica
de Cuba colapsó la noche de este martes
y la isla permanece a oscuras como
consecuencia del paso del huracán y Ana
que además a solo el extremo occidental
del país insular tras Los Fuertes
vientos y las inundaciones San Lázaro
guerra director técnico de la unión
eléctrica de Cuba dijo que una falla en
el Sistema Nacional en parte asociada a
la tormenta afectó la infraestructura
habrá trabajos hasta la madrugada de
este miércoles para restaurar la energía
el sistema eléctrico nacional tiene una
condición excepcional cero generación
eléctrica sin servicio eléctrico en el
país esta condición complicada se asocia
las afectaciones climatológicas
complejas que han afectado la
infraestructura del zen la falla está
dada en los enlaces occidentes centro y
Oriente es un proceso complejo Que para
restablecerlo se trabaja con precisión y
se irá restableciendo el sistema
eléctrico paulatinamente entre la noche
de hoy y madrugada de mañana
entre tanto en Estados Unidos el estado
de la Florida se prepara para la llegada
de Ian que impactaría como huracán
categoría 4 los residentes última
preparativos con la compra de agua
embotellada y alimentos no perecederos
en la costa este del estado más de 2,5
millones de personas tienen orden de
evacuación el gobernador ron de santis
pidió a los locales tomar todas las
precauciones y obedecer las órdenes de
abandonar las zonas de peligro el
presidente Joe biden habló con el
republicano Para ofrecerle ayuda en las
preparaciones
en general la gente está tomando las
precauciones adecuadas
cuando observa una marejada ciclónica de
esta naturaleza Es un peligro que pone
en riesgo la vida cuando habla de tres o
cuatro metros de marejada ciclónica que
podría haberse en ciertas partes cuando
toque tierra
también va a producir una gran cantidad
de lluvia va a producir grandes
inundaciones
la tormenta cuando tú que tierra se
espera que se debilite pero también irá
lento lo que significa que solo va a
estar lloviendo moviéndose a paso de
tortuga esa lluvia se va a acumular muy
rápidamente en diferentes partes del
suroeste de Florida por lo tanto estos
peligros son reales queremos que la
gente pueda tomar las precauciones
correspondientes
y seguimos en Estados Unidos porque este
martes comenzó la Selección del Jurado
para el juicio contra cinco miembros del
grupo de extrema derecha uskeepers por
su rol clave en el asalto del Capitolio
del 6 de enero de 2021 su líder stuarts
y otros cuatro acusados se encargos
federales por conspiración sediciosa y
podrían enfrentar penas de hasta 20 años
de prisión conozcamos más sobre esta
organización en el siguiente informe
se trata de un grupo paramilitar muy
hermético supremacistas organizados en
milicias antigobernamentales se hacen
llamar o skippers los guardias del
juramento este grupo de extrema derecha
estaba en la primera línea del asalto al
Capitolio al lado de otros movimientos
extremistas como quanon creado en 2009
en sus inicios ozkeepers se defendía
como un grupo de defensa de la
constitución pero enseguida se
radicalizó
al principio era un grupo de personas
que se definían como amantes de la
Constitución y que querían que sus
principios se respetaran pero
internamente las conversaciones eran
cada vez más violentas y empezaron a
considerar al gobierno como un enemigo
tirano que quiere desarmar los
ciudadanos y vulnerar la segunda
enmienda un Grupo Violento dispuesto a
derrocar la administración
estadounidense estructurado alrededor de
su fundador stewards el pasado mes de
julio delante del senado el ex portavoz
del movimiento dibujó un retrato
inquietante de la organización
una milicia peligrosa nutren gran parte
del ego sobredimensionado de Stuart
roads
Él se ve como un líder paramilitar para
mí es una organización peligrosa
distintos miembros de la organización
incluido su fundador hoy están siendo
procesados por la justicia
estadounidense acusados de complottis
edición contra el estado enfrentan hasta
20 años de prisión tres organizaciones
humanitarias denunciaron al Estado del
Salvador ante la Comisión Interamericana
de Derechos Humanos por la detención
arbitraria de al menos 152 personas
durante el régimen de decepción
declarado por el presidente nayib bukele
en su guerra contra las pandillas la
excepción que ha sido renovada cada mes
cumplió Este martes seis meses de
continuidad en los que por un lado se
mantiene alto el apoyo ciudadano al
mandatario Pero por otro hay violaciones
a los Derechos Humanos que además de
incluir detenciones arbitrarias implican
el fallecimiento de personas en custodia
y un hacinamiento en las cárceles de un
247%
enaltece
en Argentina protestó un grupo de
mujeres frente a la embajada de iraní en
Buenos Aires se unieron al rechazo y a
la rabia mundial por la muerte de maxa
aminie en la República islámica por
llevar a mal puesto el velo la
ciudadanas abogaron por la caída de la
que llamaron una dictadura religiosa y
pidieron revelarse contra las
autoridades que arrestaron a amí este
mes tres días antes de que pereciera en
coma en un hospital su pérdida ha
desatado los mayores disturbios dentro y
fuera de Irán desde 2019
quiero que la gente de todo el mundo
sepa que los iraníes los musulmanes y
las iraníes también están quemando sus
jillavos porque el hillab eso presionen
Irán en otros lugares No necesariamente
Cuando veo lo que está pasando en Irán
me siento muy feliz me siento muy
esperanzada siento que algo va a cambiar
vamos ahora a Brasil aunque los
ciudadanos evangélicos han estado en la
base de votantes del presidente
candidato Yair bolsonaro a menos de una
semana de los comicios generales en los
que Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva lleva la
delantera en las encuestas el líder del
partido de los trabajadores ha logrado
acercamientos con este grupo lo que
podría sumarle más ventaja bolsonaro
ganó el voto evangélico en 2018
defendiendo la llamada familia
tradicional y la lucha contra el aborto
sin embargo cada vez son más los que se
replantean para este domingo
especialmente mujeres en condiciones de
pobreza que sopesan las promesas de
programas sociales de Lula da Silva a
estas alturas el izquierdista está a
unos 15 puntos por encima del mandatario
según los últimos sondeos asegura que
una victoria en primera vuelta es ser
posible veamos
acto final de campaña para Luis y nació
Luna antes de una primera vuelta que el
expediente espera sea única
YouTube estamos a un paso de la Victoria
el 2 de octubre todavía nos queda un
poco de camino por recorrer en los pocos
días que quedan debemos trabajar para
ganar el voto de todos los que aman la
democracia de aquí el izquierdo
la última encuesta del instituto ipec
muestra el candidato de izquierda al
frente con 48% de las intenciones de
Voto seguido por su principal adversario
y actual presidente de Brasil Jair
bolsonaro con el 31%. según el sondeolos
la podría ganar la carrera en la primera
vuelta ya que cuenta con el 52% de apoyo
en este Duelo entonces lograr convencer
a Los partidarios de los otros
candidatos más pequeños podría ser
decisivo pero el candidato del partido
democrático laborista de Brasil Ciro
Gómez que siguió en las encuestas con el
6% de las intenciones de Voto rechazó
las presiones para una alianza con Lula
tal como los llamamientos a detener su
campaña
Aunque La Poderosa maquinaria del
lulismo y el pulsonarismo puede engañar
percepción generalizada ofreciendo La
falsa idea de que solo uno pueda vencer
al otro
el otro factor imprevisible de esta
primera vuelta es el actual mandatario
ultraderechistas revolucionario el lunes
amenazó de nuevo con cuestionar los
resultados afirmando que entregará las
llaves sin problema en elecciones
limpias poniendo en duda sin fundamento
la fiabilidad de las urnas electrónicas
un sistema electoral usado en las
elecciones en Brasil desde 1996
y terminamos en el estado de Washington
en Estados Unidos donde una compañía
presentó un modelo de avión totalmente
eléctrico se trata de Alice del
fabricante evitation aircraft que
despegó por primera vez Este martes voló
durante 8 minutos y superó los 1000
metros de altura según la compañía la
aeronave no produce emisiones de carbono
y su operación cuesta una fracción por
hora de vuelo Comparado con aviones
ligeros Alice buscará abrirse camino en
el mercado para viajes de corta
distancia en momentos en los que
preocupan las emisiones que generan las
aeronaves con su respectivo impacto en
el calentamiento global
siga con nosotros
[Música]